[Musica]
[Applauso]
sera
ora sia la tutti
grazie a questa accoglienza calorosa
vi dico subito che sono molto emozionata
quindi grazie perché avete contribuito a
rompere il ghiaccio da anni
assisto aita edx aspetto con
trepidazione che si avvicini la data e
cerco di convincere amici e familiari ad
accompagnarmi questa nella foto e mia
mamma per kate ed hicks mi ridanno
fiducia nell'umanità ad ogni evento ne
esco piena di entusiasmo e mi dico che
non va poi tutto così male che c'è
ancora speranza che le cose vengano
affrontate con spirito di innovazione
attenzione per il prossimo tutela per
l'ambiente amore per quello che si fa
mostrano un'umanità diversa attenta
inclusiva bella quest'anno
ancora una volta sono alte ma questa
volta da questa parte
sul palco a cercare mia volta di
trasmettervi un'idea dei valori delle
emozioni io sono analisa mi piace
camminare in montagna
il senso di libertà che dall essere
immersi nella natura
mi piace leggere le cene con gli amici
lo sport sono un medico una rianimatrice
lavora in un ospedale medio piccolo nel
bel mezzo della pianura padana tra il
fiume adda e il pon il mio lavoro
consiste nel prendermi cura delle
persone che sono gravemente malati che
fanno perfino fatica a respirare o il
cui cuore e fa fatica a contrarsi
persone così debilitate che non
riuscirebbero a sopravvivere senza un
aiuto immediato ea quel punto entro in
gioco io con le mie competenze
i farmaci macchinari l'esperienza
la loro vita dipende da me e il mio
unico obiettivo diventano loro capire
cosa ha determinato tutto questo
decidere la terapia e cercare di
riportare il loro organismo
all'equilibrio non è mai semplice e non
sempre ci si riesce
ma l'obiettivo è uno solo fare tutto il
possibile con tutte le energie a
disposizione per ridare salute a chi sta
perdendo la vita
e per farlo bisogna partire dalla causa
cosa alterato in modo così drammatico
l'equilibrio perfetto che regga regola
tra di loro tutte le funzioni vitali e
bisogna pensare pensare velocemente
pensare a tutto
e intanto agire dare ossigeno fluidi
farmaci pensare a quello che si ha
studiato all'esperienza fatta agli
errori e insuccessi del passato ea
quella volta in cui si ha avuto ragione
quando sei portate avanti quell idea
così remota ma che si è rivelata essere
poi l'idea vincente bisogna avere
fiducia in se stessi certo ma bisogna
soprattutto avere la volontà di portare
avanti quell idea anche se non è la più
semplice anche se non è immediata ea
volte anche se considerata impossibile
andare oltre
decidere di andare avanti
quel giorno a codogno era il 20 febbraio
ho fatto il mio lavoro come gli altri
giorni
un ragazzo giovane sano un atleta una
polmonite gravissima perché non risponde
alle terapie
qual è la causa
e se fosse davvero quel virus che tutti
noi che dobbiamo essere a km chilometri
di distanza
se invece fosse già qui con noi
e allora chiedo chiedo ancora chiedo
nuovamente la sua storia
vi faccio raccontare di nuovo tutto nei
più piccoli dettagli ma no non ci sta
non è possibile per quelle che sono le
nostre conoscenze attuali non è
possibile che si tratti di coronavirus
eppure eppure lui sta peggiorando ad una
rapidità inaudita i suoi polmoni sono
invasi da qualcosa che non riesco a
spiegarmi fino in fondo ho la
responsabilità di questo malato e su
un'ipotesi diagnostica per quanto remota
e comunque plausibile non posso esimermi
dal vagliarla fino in fondo con scrupolo
metodo tenacia
è questo il lavoro del medico è questo
che mi hanno insegnato all'università
che mi hanno insegnato i miei colleghi
più anziani curare i nostri malati e
spesso come la corsa verso la meta in
una partita di football americano non
sarà mai semplice lineare senza ostacoli
ci saranno sempre giocatori avversari
che cercheranno di trascinarci a terra e
bloccare la nostra corsa verso la meta
verso la diagnosi
un esame che è meglio non fare un
approfondimento diagnostico che si può
rimandare un protocollo che ti dice che
in questo caso non è necessario che tu
faccia il tampone e questo è un
placcaggio durissimo e anche qui come
nel football americano
la tua squadra fa la differenza non si
vince mai da soli e allora chiamo
chiamo il mio primario chiamo i miei
colleghi e loro mi danno fiducia dandomi
subito tutto il supporto di cui ho
bisogno
gli infermieri che sono con me e poi
svolgono un lavoro eccezionale senza
sosta senza mai tirarsi indietro
in meno di un'ora dal ricovero
effettuiamo il tampone lo sigilliamo e
lo inviamo all'ospedale sacco di milano
avevamo ragione purtroppo il tampone
positivo
avevamo isolato il primo caso autoctono
di coronavirus in europa
l'impatto emotivo di questa diagnosi è
immenso un virus nuovo sconosciuto di
cui si sapeva ancora pochissimo al quale
eravamo stati esposti anche noi e le
immagini di juan nel suo lock down il
reale ci ritornano alla mente
nitidissime ma non c'è tempo per la
paura siamo rianimazione
c'è un giovane uomo che sta morendo e il
nostro lavoro non si può fermare
e così continuiamo a farlo
ininterrottamente lo curiamo per due
giorni di fila isolati da tutto il resto
del mondo senza far entrare in reparto
nessuno che non sia strettamente
necessario per noi per non esporre
nessuno al contagio ma più le ore
passano più i casi sospetti aumentano
235 focolaio epidemia pandemia fuori
dall'ospedale si accalcano giornalisti e
telecamere
siamo di fronte a qualcosa di molto più
grande di noi all'inizio di un'emergenza
mai vista e noi
facciamo l'unica cosa che possiamo fare
una cosa importantissima
diamo l'allarme attenzione il virus a
qui da quel momento tutti gli operatori
sanitari
iniziano di indossare dispositivi di
protezione individuale i pazienti
ricoverati in ospedale vengono
sottoposti a tampone e vengono isolati
casi positivi
da quel momento la consapevolezza della
possibilità del contagio ha consentito a
tutti noi di proteggerci limitando la
diffusione di un virus che fino a quel
momento stava circolando indisturbato
e così in un piccolo ospedale di
provincia
andando oltre i protocolli abbiamo dato
tutto per salvare una vita contribuendo
in questo modo a salvarne tantissime
non importa chi sei che ruolo rivesti
che lavoro fai e dove lo fi che tu sia
medico insegnante artista outside eroina
sider dai sempre il massimo e farlo con
passione amore emozione e quando hai un
idea se davvero ci credi portal avanti
fino in fondo
[Applauso]